o lado pessoal de quem fala é o dar que
sejam muito bem vindos já mais um
guerreiro
ontem à noite psi mesmo julgar qualquer
coisa eu queria também aproveitar essa
vontade de jogar e gravar mas eu não
podia gravar porque já eram três da
manhã então eu não pude fazer muito
barulho mas depois uma voz de interior
dentro do meu coração disse tarso tem
levantado vaz pronto eu gravei um vídeo
as três também é 3 também é que é a hora
do moneo lado santanás mas é isso
pessoal espero que vocês gostem do vídeo
ficou sem um vídeo uma jovem que curte
um vídeo de quatro minutos mas espero
que vocês gostem a mesma já sabem quanto
com o próximo ranking e favorito junto
de punir pronto vídeo da foto o chute e
definiu a hora que o 2 lugar e aqui
vamos sair não conseguiu mais que um
empate não interessa
aí porque eu não consigo mexer em nada o
entrei steel que chama só teu amor se eu
acho que não disse o nome mas já é
alguma coisa sem partido e eu tenho que
jogar um papel neto inter ect iene está
grávida nós não planejamos e isto mexe e
ovo é aceitar nós vamos passar por isto
vamos casar em alguma coisa sem possível
dormir muito porque o meu inglês vocês
já sabem que é bom nesta mário abreu
caiu 14 brasil está muito silêncio em
uma música de fundo um dos jogos não tem
musiquinha de fundo é porque isto vai
burlar isto abre ó permeou a porta não
fugiu à filha o estilo que estava
disponível procos rift mas eu não ia ter
um só consegui ver esta hora não é
porque estão aí é que morria que também
não abre
vamos com calma eu não posso gritar e eu
não posso gritar som quatro da manhã
quatro atriz já nem sei que não me
deixam uma polícia é pra vir à minha
casa
segurar minha cueca é porque nada disso
funciona é só andar pelo corredor é isso
porque como o rato tatu mago koch e sim
este é um pijama vocês podem ver russo
barco por causa da cheia vai não é mais
fácil embora tal uma bucha piscava não
tinham abreu to oitavas de final e à
frente oca dúvida uma coisa brilhar que
aquilo uma chapa enquanto protesto opera
não sei se já o jovem bruno é como é que
isto aconteceu e obina se pareceu com
nosso pé e não pode ser vamos encontrar
o nosso dever nem que seja um demônio
temos que salvar a criança não percebo
bem mas vamos continuar uma porta abriu
foi esta a porta e vê nessa estratégia o
demônio no corpo mente não vetava aí eu
sou pai tenho direito eu acho que seu
pai não sair eu não sei que isso voltei
ao quarto principal ar que controla uma
folha em branco
meu deus ainda não sabe escrever ela é
analfabeta dica analfabeta não sabe que
tem que fazer agora
[ __ ] do sul
o ultimato europeu por meio de uma
passagem secreta menina que é isto
o tapete está a deitar uma [ __ ] do chão
é que lê pó você contrata uma empregada
por mim para o xampu
aí está o garoto estava programada e não
posso ficar num luxo
joana acha aí o e na tela de 13 4 não
funciona uma tecla estragavam essa aqui
na itália tem o papel de helena onde
está suu kyi nem detalhes a torcida
isto é pisar para caraças porque não
abro nenhum depois aparecem os barulhos
do capeta pela gestão papel lei eu acho
que sim
ok vamos lá na frente estamos quase no
fim eu acho pelo menos ele não há
nenhuma saída só uma porta não abria
meu deus o gostoso é um hotel mostrou
cartazes têm outras chaves
qualquer pessoa ou por onde eu vou pôr
um pouco do que estava a falar com ela
estava a falar com o meu jeitinho é
inscrito gera estava a falar com os meus
respeitos aí para nós queremos pagar o
que me embora pra que então a não tá
tudo certo e vou morrer e matar ou
morrer
estamos mandando ok ok
esperem só um minuto e outro colega
também está